hello everybody I still don't know what
part this is but I'm getting right back
into it ah I just had to go do some
manly things benchpress an elephant jump
around the house 50 times okay
I'm ready to go oh where am I
where am I Oh bring it on Oh you guys
aren't scary
I wasn't even a little scared this is an
orb pedestal don't tell me there are
orbs in this game mystical orbs of
unrealistic power oh boy okay I'm ready
whatever I'm cool I'm calm and collected
I got it all together ooh thank you okay
up jumping all leap jumping skills Oh
mega ultra come on come on what's that
all about I just dusted a dick move
right there
yeah whatever fine fine whatever still
bleeding
this my vision isn't blood red anymore
all right whatever fine
Omega leap Ultra jumping skill I'm not
trusting that one get out of here
all right whoa what the hell what what
oh what I can't use my fire
you did know okay I got a bone saw
surprise that grabbed creatures I don't
trust you
oh no don't make oh good golly I don't
want to go back not that I'm scared it's
just it I don't want to have to make
that monster face me yeah that's it
that's it
it's totally it alright alright I can do
it I can do it get a knife I can do it
oh boy all right library either
Oh F me okay who could I trust was that
really the same Gordon from his notes
was it this mad god in disguise my own
thoughts feel as though they're turning
on me oh no I don't remember this music
from anything in amnesia this is freaky
freaky stuff oh okay I'm okay okay okay
keeping it together I know the dialogue
for the past few oh I got it I got it I
got it oh I got it I got it I got it
get out here get out here get out here
oh I got it oh thank goodness it was
right there oh he's right there it was
right there I was right there okay I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay
I bet I bet it was a stroke of luck that
I found that phone song [ __ ] okay
because man it was an obscure corner
tucked behind like a dog head or
something okay oh man all right let's
get me out of here
Oh epic to eat Oh super mega awesome oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah you are still
creepy man I don't know if I trust you
buddy the sacrificial oyster ritual
to remove our uh-huh
okay okay shut up what what are you
doing please the big Israel
what am I supposed to do banished
creatures what yeah yeah wonderful yes
yeah you don't need to ask me twice
I'll banish the monsters in here whack
smack oh yeah get him oh yeah I'm so did
Ethan those monsters better watch our
already
yeah it's gross
oh boy alright okay Journal okay let us
please banish these demons oh please
please let me banish the demons
oh please good gracious Oh what that
doesn't look like a heart that's a piece
of orb wait where'd his head go well I
mean I think I know I removed it Oh get
me out of here Oh get me out of here
this is a mistake I shouldn't have
trusted him right what why not why not
oh there we go what what what no no no
no no let me go let me go let me go let
me go let me go let me go let me go
right no oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh oh
ran into his legs nearly gave up huh
once he thought he was foreigner oh stop
moves back in the temple he heard no
more screams of terror okay but in his
mind he thought he heard
oh thank you thank you you're welcome
buddy oh wow
ninjas Samurai you are an evil genius
Russ money equal minister owl very good
oh man oh wow oh that's all I can say
I'm tempted I'm tempted to just say to
everyone don't play this game because it
will give you a heart attack but it is
so great I cannot not recommend him whoa
that deserved to win the contest
I haven't even played the other ones but
I aim to the runners-up but man oh man
oh I've never had my hands shake so much
I thought nightmare house 2 was good but
you know when I first looked at custom
games and I thought about these games I
thought they couldn't be anywhere nearly
as good as the actual games that they
made but honest to gosh that was
incredible very well made deserved all
the honors a gift deserve to win the
contest no question about it oh man oh
and I hope you guys enjoyed it because I
know it's been a while since I screamed
like a little girl and that definitely
fit the bill
not gonna lie so I'm gonna play the
other games in the list the runner up in
the second runner up but if you guys
know any good amnesia custom stories
definitely write them in the comments
let me know send me a message do
something um just get it to me somehow
and I will play them because that was
incredible I know that there are many
other custom stories that are probably
on the same level of terrifying and I
love to play them I would love to play
them for you guys and I would love to
record it and let you guys listen to me
scream like a little girl oh man that
was fantastic
so hope you enjoyed this I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be mixing in these custom
stories in between my other Let's Plays
of the bigger games and
Knots horror games so you you always get
a dose I know some of you like me just
for the horror games I'm gonna try to
give you what you want along with doing
big-name games so thank you guys so much
for watching
I always appreciate it I appreciate
every one of you can't thank you enough
so I'm gonna keep making these if you
let me know what custom stories you want
to see or if any other horror games you
want to see so thanks again for watching
I will see you in the next game bye bye